justice is a funny thing for the poor
it's what keeps them alive and starving
depending on how the local Lord feels
about his woods his streams is crops for
the rich justice is what you get if
you're not careful enough or rich enough
usually how it works is you commit a
crime and the local Lord sends his
guards after you or your victim's family
kills you and the guards go after them
instead or you do nothing and the guards
come after you anyway either way someone
is brought before the Lord and he
decides what's to be done it could be a
fine if you're rich enough to pay
otherwise it's the dungeons the chopping
block or the wall
you'd think most folks would choose the
war the north is nasty dark and cold but
so are most dungeons and every man knows
how the Nights Watch earn their name all
they can do is watch I don't blame the
men who choose a quick chop rather than
life without one of its few joys if
you're in the capital it's the King's
justice who takes you out elsewhere in
the south the headsman of the local lord
but in the north it's the Lord Himself
the man who passes the sentence should
swing the sword they say out there
sounds noble but given some of the
northern Lords eyes mate they just don't
want anyone else spoiling their fun if
you're so unlucky to be in the Vale when
you're caught you might never make it to
sentencing thanks to their sky cells
open on one side to a long fall with the
floor sloping down towards it like a
woman's thighs after a few days they say
the sky starts calling to you men jump
with smiles on their faces expecting the
wind to lift them into the sky it
doesn't to think Lord Tyrion was one tit
shaped cloud away from death lucky for
him he was highborn if your family honor
goes back hundreds of years to a time
when your ancestors hid other men harder
than they were hid you have another
option trial by combat you either fight
your accuser or you both pick champions
to fight on your behalf and the gods
will favour the righteous man as long as
he's also the strongest the quickest or
the luckiest once in a long while you
may get two real highborn ships have an
authority
each other and one of them might be fool
enough to demand a trial by seven
exactly how it sounds seven men against
seven men
thanks for the good show I guess but any
man who's been in battle knows that the
more men involved the less skill needed
the more chance of accidents just ask
that Targaryen Prince who got his head
stabbed in by his brother all those
years ago and all for some hedge Knight
if he ever find yourself arrested in the
Seven Kingdoms just remember that
justice is up to the judge
beg him for forgiveness or paying for it
or ask to be allowed to take the black
but remember that he doesn't have to let
you there are plenty of lords out there
who think hands and eggs are great
decorations for their spikes the septons
claim that justice is of the gods nice
of them to keep it up there to
themselves